[تصفيق]
يتفقوا عسكريون غربيون ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا في طريقها للتوسع والانتقال الى
حرب مدمره ويعزون السبب للبدء بوصول اسلحه
غربيه ثقيله الى اوكرانيا الدعم الغربي
ولكيف نقل الاخيره من الدفاع الى الهجوم
نحو عشرات الدبابات يتامل الغرب ان تغير
وضع القوات الاوكرانيه على الارض بشكل
جذريا لصالحها الا ان موسكو تردوا بتوقعات
معاكسه مؤكده ان الدبابات الغربيه لن تغير
المعادله على الارض لا تقتصر الحزمه
الجديده من الاسلحه على دبابات اليوبارز
بل انتقلت المساعدات الى المستوى اخر من
الدعم
بالمدرعات من طراز برادل
ومضادات الالغام للتواغل في مناطق سيطره
الروس اسلحه هجوميه با
ومقابلك كل سلاح غربيه هجومي تضع روسيا
سلاحا رادعا ربما لا يقل شده عن نظيره
وكان الرد الروسي على قرار الاسلحه
الجديده
وبلا من الصواريخ على مدن اوكرانيه ووعيدا
بادخال اسلحه اقوى الى ساحه الحرب
وبينما تامر القوات الاوكرانيه ان تشرن
هجوما خلال الربيع منتهيه فرصه ان روسيا
تستجمع قواها وتجدد امداداتها من الذخيره
والسلاح يتوقع ان يتخذ الرئيس الروسي
بلادي مير بوتين خطوه السباقيه قبل حزمه
المساعدات العسكريه ويشونه هجوما جديدا
على اوكرانيا
فبراير القادم بحسب ما نشرته
ان ياتون الحرب ستكون في ذروتها ولا ربما
ستمتد حمامها لدول الجوار ايضا اذا عمر
العربيه